Carl Rogers who's a psychotherapist
great psychotherapist I'd very much
recommend his books to people especially
if they want to learn to listen because
he was really good at teaching people
how to listen he had this idea that what
he would manifest towards his clients in
therapy was unconditional positive
regard and I've always had trouble with
that because well because you don't
treat your children for example with
unconditional positive reviews there's
no matter what someone says you're
saying yeah that's a good idea well
that's that's why it's tricky well what
do you what do you he didn't articulate
it I think as well as he might have what
you want to do is for your child is that
you want the best for the best in them
that's what you want and that's what you
want from people that you surround
yourself with
now they'll hold you to our standard if
that's the case right because whenever
you degenerate in any of the multiple
ways that you're likely to degenerate
they're gonna like whack you on the back
of the head and say you know clue the
hell in you know you're you're demeaning
yourself you're less than you could be
and there's real judgment and then it's
harsh you know but with friends it's the
same thing you want friends they're not
friends if they're not these people you
want friends who when something good
happens to you there that's good for you
right they're happy about that they're
not like all bitter and resentful
underground and like saying horrible
things behind your back and telling you
how they did something that was better
and trying to drag you down it's like
that's not helpful and then when
something bad happens to you and you go
to them and you say look this terrible
thing happened to me first of all they
don't try to top it with some like
horrible thing that happened to them
because they don't have the patience to
listen and second they're not secretly
gloating about the fact that catastrophe
finally befell you it's like they're
actually hurt by it and that chapters an
injunction is like take a look at the
people that are around you and if
they're not on the side of what's good
for you then walk away because well
first of all that's best for them too if
you put up with that all you're doing is
enabling it it's like well it's okay
that you mistreat me in a way that's
harmful to me and everyone else it's
like actually no that is not okay it's
not in it's not the least bit
okay that doesn't mean you shouldn't try
to help someone when they're down that's
a whole different issue what if it's
your family so you know you say like
walk away right yeah
do you still walk away from your family
or do you do if it's necessary yeah
there's lots of different ways of
walking away oh yeah don't forget about
well there's that for sure there's that
I mean you you sometimes someone's on an
encouraging path like there's just
nothing you can do you know maybe
they're a man down there a man down hard
and they're bitter and everything they
do is to produce misery virtually
everything and you have to detach
yourself from that's like I always think
about it from the perspective of a
lifeguard so if you're training to be a
lifeguard one of the things that you're
trained to do is to approach someone
who's drowning and panicking and the way
you approach them is you put your foot
out between you and them and you push
forward with your hands with your foot
out and you basically tell them if
they're flailing about you say look I'm
here to help but you have to calm down
and then if they cling to you like in
panic you push them away you think well
that's pretty damn cruel because what if
they drown it's like yeah what if you
both drowned that's like not helpful
you're you're there to rescue them they
take you down you're both dead
it's like fail right so you say look
quit panicking I'll help you out but I'm
not drowning along with you it's like
well it's the same with someone in your
family it's like if they're on a
downward path and you've done your best
you know you've made your efforts you
and they're not paying attention they're
not changing they say yeah well I'll
quit doing this yeah I'll quit doing
this they tell you the same story over
and over and over it's a downhill path
you don't trust it at some point first
of all you stop offering your words
that's do not cast pearls before swine a
very very harsh statement right but what
it means is if someone if you're
offering words of wisdom to someone in
the genuine attempt help and they treat
that with contempt then shut up because
you're demeaning your words by throwing
them away you think well how do you help
someone who's a
down well sometimes you help them by
walking away and saying look you're
aiming down so hard that I am the spite
the fact you're my brother man it's like
you know this is killing me you're
aiming down so hard I'm not coming along
with you and the reason I'm not is to
tell you in no uncertain terms that what
you're doing is so terrible that I will
even violate our kinship to oppose it
and maybe it'll take them 10 years to
wake up to that you know and something
that can be the case because you know
people often have to be hit so many
times before they learn you see that
especially if someone's addicted or or
otherwise pursuing a pathway that's like
seriously downhill so yeah are you poor
you cover that pretty well in that
chapter where you're saying there's a
certain point where you just gotta say
you know we're done yeah we're done
we're done well it's like why should I
think that you're actually trying to
change maybe you're just telling me is
your you tell me the story that you use
to justify your own idiocy to yourself
and then you tell it to me and you
demand that because I'm compassionate I
accept it and therefore validate your
excuse it's like well that like it's
really hard not to get tangled up in
that right because if someone who's
really in rough shape is telling you
about why they're suffering first of all
they're probably about half right in
their story but some of its
justification and excuse and blaming and
all of that failure to take
responsibility it's really hard to stand
up and say no I don't buy that no I
don't buy that no you're wrong about
that you have to be a brutal bastard in
order to do that but hey sometimes like
surgery is brutal right
it's brutal but they're allowed to cut
you open and we're gonna rip out part of
your body however right right exactly
right precisely and so so this chapter
about you know only making friends with
people who want the best for you that's
a brutal chapter you know but it's right
unfortunately